world leaders are drawing up a pact
aimed at preventing another pandemic
the second day of the g7 summit in the
united kingdom will also focus on
climate change
and the gathering of the biggest global
economies will see a push for more
western cohesion
against challenges from russia and china
it's the first time these global leaders
have got together in person
since the start of the pandemic
with the spotlight on a green recovery
britain's queen elizabeth was the star
of a gala dinner at a futuristic
botanical garden
are you supposed to be looking at as if
you're enjoying it yes
hosting the proceedings british prime
minister boris johnson
i think that is what the people of the
uh
of our countries now want us to to focus
on they want us
to be sure that we're beating the
pandemic together and
discussing how we'll never have a repeat
of what we've seen
but also that we're building back better
together
and building that greener and building
that fairer
and building back more equal
g7 leaders agree a joint approach is the
only way to end the pandemic
and tackle the climate crisis we need
everyone across the world to want to
work together
especially on the issue of climate
protection and biodiversity
where we will never find solutions
without china
hundreds of climate change protesters
marched to bring their message
as near to the summit venue as they
could get
[Music]
so we've got a situation post covered
with developing countries
drowning in debt as a result of covid
failing to get vaccines
and failing to get the climate finance
they need to help them
mitigate their emissions and adapt to
the climate crisis
so it's a situation of staggering
inequity
and we feel that this needs to be
brought to the attention of the g7
leaders
as day one of the summit drew to a close
activists staged a vigil
to remember the estimated 3.7 million
people
who've died in the pandemic
they'll be looking for more definite
measures to emerge
before the gathering wraps up
dw correspondent alexander van naman is
in carbus bay cornwall where
the g7 is taking place this weekend uh
alexandra what specific proposals are
percolating there to tackle climate
change which
of course many see as the single
greatest long-term challenge
facing the world today
yes this is definitely very high on the
agenda here the g7 leaders are going to
discuss
climate change tomorrow there are two
key questions i would say first of all
of course
what measures have to be implemented to
reach the goal of
zero emissions by 2050 and
the other question is whether the g7
will live up to their promise to provide
more financial support to developing
countries to help them
adapt to climate change consequences and
switch to green energy the us
administration
is promising here tangible climate
action but it is
actually the european union that is
leading the way
they have decided to spend
their covet recovery funds mostly on
green
energy and on green economy and they're
hoping that
the rest of the g7 will follow
no doubt you are aware u.n secretary
general antonio guterres
has made a dramatic appeal to the g7
nations to do more to tackle climate
change
let's listen into what he had to say
about this
we are in a situation in the world where
the average temperature rise in relation
to pre-industrial levels is already 1.2
degrees
very close to the 1.5 degrees that
international
scientific community tells us is the
limit to avoid the catastrophic
developments in the world
so to a certain extent we are on the
verge of the peace
and when we are on the verge of dps we
need to make sure that the next step is
on the right direction
um cautionary words to say the least
alexandria are the secretary general's
words
likely to move leaders towards a
stronger position
well he will be here to participate in
the discussion so you
we can expect him to reiterate his
message
will the leaders listen they should
experts say
according to latest studies they
are at risk at losing eight percent of
their gdp
each year when they are not going to
tackle climate change
the other big issue on the agenda this
weekend is tackling the pandemic of
course
are leaders united on that
well so far they seem to be united
they have pledged to donate at least 1
billion
vaccine doses to low and middle income
countries
to vaccinate the world until 2022
that is not enough but of course
progress when we consider that many rich
countries were accused of hoarding
vaccines only a few months ago the
leaders
have also agreed to establish a global
pandemic
raider to identify new covet 19
variants but there is one controversial
issue on the table
the question whether it makes sense to
lift
intellectual property rights on covet 19
vaccines and we have here
the u.s supporting this proposal friends
saying that they are ready to talk
but germany is still pretty much against
that
that's alexander von naman at the g20
summit in
england as always many thanks alexandra
a short time ago i talked to alexander
graf lamstoff a german lawmaker and
former vice president
of the european parliament i asked him
to respond to criticism that the g7's
plans to share at least
one billion shots with developing
countries has come too late
the european union has made a great
effort to step up to its obligation
early on
then there was the global program called
kovacs it's a reality that the united
states and the united kingdom
have not exported vaccines so if
the u.s and the uk now join the eu
in looking out for the countries of the
global south i think that's a very good
development okay well demonstrative
unity
warm words a relaxed atmosphere
generally
is the collegiality we're seeing simply
the hope of a post-trump era
or is it a reflection of real
substantive policy agreements
well both i mean michael we've probably
also seen these images from the g7
meetings where donald
trump was in attendance to everybody's
irritation
um it was a um how should i say a very
unusual way of handling the summit
meetings by
the then europe u.s president joe biden
is somebody everybody knows
um the united states are back in a
stronger position the economic recovery
is
strong their vaccine campaign has gone
well
and joe biden is well first of all he's
a he's a man
you can deal with a man of his word and
it's it's
somebody who will listen to his allies
around the table as you can see by the
way
from the choreography of the coming days
it's now g7 it's going to be nato
then eu and only then is he going to
meet the russian president putin so
the western world has come together at
this g7 meeting and i think that's a
very good
signal you mentioned president putin so
let's focus on russia for a moment trump
wanted to bring
president putin back to the g7 table
biden comes with the promise of calling
putin out
instead of cozying up to him what do you
think the g7's message to russia
should be well first of all that there
is a united
view of russia's policies concerning
ukraine there's a there's the illegal
annexation of crimea
there is the civil war supported by
russia
fomented by russia in eastern ukraine
a country that russia promised to
protect when ukraine gave back its
nuclear weapons
in 1994 russia promised to protect
the territorial integrity of ukraine by
and large russia's policies are
aggressive and unfriendly
and i think to have the western meetings
as i said g7 nato and eu before
the u.s russian summit i think the
signal is very strong
that the americans are now looking for
western unity
and i think they'll be able to come up
with it
as well well the list of problem solving
is long economic recovery after the
pandemic
unified action a plan to protect the
world's lands and oceans to fight
climate change
but as chancellor merkel mentioned china
isn't even there
how substantial can the results be
without a central world player like
china
well of course the g7 cannot save the
world the g7 was
you know originally started out as an
informal gathering
around a fireplace of western leaders to
talk
without media present without diplomats
without advisors
as a very small informal setting it has
turned
into a sort of you know a meeting
that that everybody takes an interest in
but it has never
you know claimed to solve the world's
problems the united nations are for that
uh the g20 is for that but it's not uh
the place where the world's problems are
soft it's the word it's the place
where western liberal democracies gather
to compare notes and to agree on certain
steps and then
in the next step you talk to countries
outside of the g7
to bring them on board or to listen to
their ideas
demands and and and uh yes and
and hammer out compromises with them and
and try to find solutions with them
german lawmaker alexander graf lamsdoff
really do appreciate your time and your
perspective
thank you